okay currently in the US and I'm an
Australia but I want to send her a
present a cute and fluffy presently
there's just one problem and that's the
cats hate water
and there's a lot of water between here
and Pittsburgh a boat of the nose and a
plane would be too uncomfortable
I think I'll simply have to teleport her
classically all I would need to do is
record the exact structure of it send
that data to Jade and have her print it
out on the other side using a
sophisticated 3d printer well even if
the resolution of that printer was
extremely high the task of measuring the
exact structure of something is not so
simple when you consider the quantum
nature of reality to be able to record
the exact structure of the cat I would
need to record the momentum and position
of every particle however this is
impossible due to the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle which says that
the more I know about one of these
quantities the less I know about the
other I'll never be able to gain enough
information to create an exact blueprint
even if I could the process of measuring
individual particles would probably kill
the cat before I could make an exact
copy there is however an alternative
form of teleportation and that is
quantum teleportation making use of
something called quantum entanglement
quantum teleportation would not be able
to suspend a cat but at least Jade would
get something from me I'm going to
attempt to send the contents of this box
box a to her box box see on the other
side of the world the contents of this
box is quantum information and that is
something that can't be communicated
over the phone or internet quantum
information tells us something about the
state of a quantum system such as
whether a particle is turned up or spin
down spin relates to the fact that when
you put particles through a magnetic
field they act like little magnets and
can get deflected up or down one way
that objects can get magnetic properties
and I spinning like a planet which is
why we use the word spin although what
is important is that it's something
about the particles that makes them get
deflected some ups come down when
they're put through a magnetic field
it's just two distinct orientation
so how does quantum teleportation work
where the information needs to be
centered to entangled particles when a
particle which spins be educated to two
particles with spin half the total spin
after the decay still needs to be zero
this is because of the conservation of
angular momentum this means that the to
detect particles need to have opposite
spin one spoon up and the other spin
down so remember that quantum physics is
a bit weird and particles and ensures
estate when they're being measured until
then they exist in a superposition of
all possible states so say I go back to
Australia and Toby and I go and collect
these two decayed particles she takes
one home to Canberra and I take one to
Pittsburgh but the whole time neither
were supposed to see which one we have
so both particles are in this real
content state with a 50/50 chance at
collecting into spin-up or spin-down
point measures as soon as one of us
looks into our box our particle
collapses is just spin up or spin down
but the crazy thing is as the exact same
time the other particle on the other
side of the world collapses there's any
other de state this happens
instantaneously there was no time or
means for one particle to communicate to
the other these particles are said to be
entangled and they seem to somehow
magically knows the state of the other
Einstein corpus tsuki action at a
distance as it went against everything
he thought he knew about physics and it
turned out we can use it through T
action to do quantum teleportation so
quantum teleportation should really be
called quantum communication because
we're not actually teleporting anything
typical with chemical information which
is pretty much communication and then
speaking a telegram you're not actually
sending the physical message you're
sending the information through to
Telegraph's this is how quantum
teleportation work but with two speed
differences instead of sending
information between two Telegraph's
we're sending information between two
entangled particles also we're sending a
quantum information which is a bit
different from classical
information for one quantum information
needs to be embedded in a quantum
particle and two quantum information
can't be copied or discrete and here's a
fun fact a bit of quantum information is
called a qubit if Toby in Canberra wants
to send me accusers in Pittsburgh it
needs to be embedded in a third high
level which we'll call particle X so now
Toby has particle X and the first part
of the entangled pair of particles which
we'll call particle a she wants to send
a qubit from particle X to my entangled
particle which we'll call particle B she
can do this by performing a quantum
operation on her particles which due to
the entanglement makes the qubit from
particle X appear on particle B but
because clinton information can't be
copied or destroyed the original qubit
on Toby's particle X is now transformed
into something else this all took
probably tempted to call this
teleportation because now my life will
be is effectively so beautiful X it's
kind of like when you're flexing
something the piece of paper on the
receiving end isn't the same as the one
that was sent but all the information is
the same the difference between this and
quantum teleportation is that the
original information is transformed into
something else in the person but this
isn't the whole picture so this a
quantum information that we need from
highschool X to get the particle B can't
be sent through the two entangled
particles we need a classical means of
communication like the internet or a
phone a lot of people think that quantum
teleportation means that we can
communicate faster than the speed of
life but it's not true remember that we
still need this classical channel to
transport some of the information this
is all beautifully encapsulated and
popping for the corpse DiNozzo's theorem
it says that information can be
communicated by entanglement alone you
need the classical channel so that
relativity remains safe so
faster-than-light communication is a
no-go
so will we ever be able to transport
cups well look
[Music]
hey Jade
I sent your prison go check your box hey
cool quantum information a big thanks to
Jade for making this video with me
please go and subscribe to her channel
there is also a link to subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
please post any questions or thoughts
about quantum teleportation down below